Reggie Miller called the Warriors in
Blazers last night as Damian Lillard had
61
he's got mavericks and blazers coming up
on thursday that'll be 10:30 Eastern on
TNT we were talking about Damian Lillard
that put up 61 but I don't know how many
people will talk about the fact that he
put up 61 your thoughts on watching
Lillard last and granted it's against
Golden State this isn't the Golden State
from a couple of years ago a little
performance last night thinking about
this short-handed didn't have his
running mate in CJ McCollum out with the
high ankle sprain possibly could be back
this Thursday versus Dallas but it's
unbelievable shooting performance
carrying a team because at one point and
again Golden State which were headed as
well they've been like this all seasons
but they were playing with a bunch of
feebly guys and pretty much was
controlling a temple the paints and the
style of play the milord got hot he
stayed hot made ten threes but you're
right a lot of people won't talk about
it because a was a West Coast game but
over topic was late a lot of people did
the basketball Pierce did but just a
phenomenal offensive performance by
Lillard if I said you can have Damian
Lillard or James Harden is that obvious
well I would have to ask what style of
play because they both play the style of
play a lot of isolation basketball I
believe in James Harden at number one
isolation plays and Jane Damian Lillard
is probably third with Russell Westbrook
either two or four because they both
like the same style play it's a lot of
isolation high screen basketball there's
not a lot of passes so who can you win
with if I said you're starting your team
and look I'm down on James Harden
today this season you know you go 1 for
17 from three-point range he's playing
too many minutes
there has to be a point where Mike
D'Antoni said says to him make the extra
pass here let's just see if there's
something else there or you can get an
easier shot he doesn't make it easy on
himself you know he wanted to pass the
basketball to a team well Russell
Westbrook on shooter shooter he's old al
you wouldn't he drive I just don't know
if Harden is so far down the road that
this is this is the style that he can
play and wants to play I think this is
his style and I would be curious if you
could have or surrounded him for
instance let's say with a Steve Kerr
where they have what three hundred and
thirtysomething passes during the game
yeah the problem with the Warriors they
just they don't have you know kg and
staff and clay shooters if you put them
in a system where the ball is moving and
then you know when it gets you know six
to eight seconds left on the shot clock
at the ball along to you then you make a
play I would be curious to see that I
understand your frustration and a lot of
people's frustration with hearted but to
me it's style of play that's a head
coaching issue as well as personnel
throw more we miss you because who do
you want him to pass the ball to and I
agree he's playing way to minutes we
look we are enamored and we marvel at
James Harden during the regular season
because he puts up these gaudy numbers
when he has these 50 and 60 point games
and he makes you know 10 to 15 threes it
looks great when he's tired and he's not
shooting the ball well if he goes 1 for
17 3 then the frustration comes out like
past the ball dude who do you want to
pass it to though well I wouldn't have
brought in Russell Westbrook first of
all you know I I would have looked to
have found somebody who is a shoot you
know an off guard shooting guard and not
somebody who needs to have the ball all
the time you know you're not gonna find
klay Thompson but you need to find
somebody who moves without the ball when
he gets the ball then he's a knock
shooter you know maybe it's a if it's a
Devin Booker or somebody like you just
need something in there that it feels
like you can count on and throw it to
them and be confident I just don't think
that he's confident with anybody I don't
think those players expect the ball and
last night you just can't can't go great
players don't go 1 for 17 he's had at
least 10 misses in a game this year from
three-point range
I think like you know 12 times I mean
it's been crazy but what he's first I
just personally think he's getting a
little bit warmer down a lot of minutes
and this style it wears on you
any settling I think he's always been
one of the great drivers in our game
where he can initiate contact and step
back I think he's just suddenly because
the reason why he's 17 he's hired it
lead the league in minutes reg because
every postseason what do we say about
James Harden he's time runs out of gas
yes it's gonna happen again gonna happen
again that's more personnel you're
you're you're more so down on James
Harden the player where you need to look
at people that are making the decisions
for James Hart okay I'll be down on
daryl morey as well okay all right I
will be angry at Daryl Morey right now
the Lakers get blown out in Boston big
deal little deal no deal little deal not
a big deal there what 39 and eight four
games ahead of Denver who was currently
second there eight and two over there
last ten and a lot of those wins came
without Anthony Davis though one of the
top five players in the game it's a
little deal to me it's it's a blip now
if you tell me they were five and five
if they lost a lot of those games you
know while Anthony Davis was out to me
it'd be a little bit bigger deal but
it's one game on the road against a
franchise where there's history so it's
it's one game okay but it feels like
something is missing or were led to
leave there's something missing with the
Lakers so what is it when they have
everybody is there still something
missing with this team in my opinion no
I think you would probably want more
consistency in their shooting from you
know caldwell-pope or Danny Green you'd
probably want a little bit more
consistency and rounding into shape if
you're Kuzma
I think shooting will always be the
issue with them if they are shooting the
basketball for three because LeBron is
driving and collapsing the defense and
Anthony Davis is getting double and
triple team if those guys that we I just
mentioned are knocking down threes the
Lakers are unbeatable shooting will
always be the issue to me come playoff
time if those guys are hitting I'm fine
when they struggle the Laker struggle is
Kyle Koosman still in the trading block
I wouldn't trade them I don't know what
piece they can get to improve thirty
nine and eight thirty nine and eight
what about the possible bring it in I
wouldn't trade him either especially he
doesn't cost you anything what about
bringing in Derrick Rose this is almost
the same situation we're talking about
what James Harden for Derrick Rose to be
successful what does he have to do be
how no mall in it yeah he's bald
dominate he's got to have the ball in
his hand that takes the ball out of
LeBron James hands so no I don't think
that would be a great fit the Lakers for
Derrick Rose playing fantastic playing
great but I don't think give the Lakers
to be a great destination for them by
the way Kemba Walker finally beat LeBron
James no I didn't know that but I think
Michael Jordan beats somebody 30 30 out
of 30 time McLovin do you know that
Sherman Sherman Douglas lost all 30
games he faced Michael Jordan
I mean I wouldn't put the cable Walker
is a as an all-star Sherpa Douglas was
never and also I don't believe you know
that's a little surprising that Kimball
Walker was was it Owen twenty eight
until last night yeah yeah
twenty-eight Sian makes it look at the
team game I mean it's a it's a unique
stat but uh I was little I was a little
taken back by that I was a little
surprised by that
Xion makes his debut tomorrow night
wrench I'll believe it when I see it I
I'm happy for this young man you know
we've been going back and forth saying
they should sell them but you know
obviously you know the general manager
David Griffin them have different plans
so we'll see I know he'll be on a
minutes restriction what are we looking
fifteen minutes followed Lee tomorrow
twenty yeah I mean I don't know you know
but what happens sometimes if somebody
gets out there to get into a rhythm and
then you don't want to take them out but
I just figured that if you get him out
there let him see how he feels and but
now you know now the pelicans have been
playing well yeah and now you have to
start think about can we make the
playoffs how badly do you want to make
the playoffs this year and then that
that's gonna factor into his minutes
there are what three and a half four
behind that age spot in the Western
Conference holiday is they're playing
off the charts forty nine points for red
and Ingram I believe in that big win
over time versus Utah so the pieces are
there and now you're addy the future
face of the franchise an explosive
player I mean there's a lot of upside
into bringing him back because these
other guys are playing well so he
doesn't have to do as much I just hope
he does it reactivate or something
happens where you have to show him and
shut him down now I did say in the
preseason when he was healthy that he
wasn't going to win the Rookie of the
Year John Moran to me has lived up to
that billing he has been spectacular
and if I see okay moving forward you can
redraft would you change anything Reggie
Miller
no knowing what we know now correct yep
and I don't get a chance to see him
tomorrow and you how he plays no blows
no right nope I'm still gonna go in Zion
because he puts people in the seat okay
John Moran is a better player I think I
right now he's a better player because
he's at court time but if I'm a journal
manager and I'm in a small market like
darlin and I want to put people in the
seats and I'm gonna be a traveling show
I'm gonna draft a Zion yeah I understand
that and I I agree with that logic if
Memphis in and it's not fair to ask this
at Memphis but I will if Memphis had the
opportunity right now and you could take
Jama rant knowing what you know or you
could have Zion there would Memphis take
Zion because they're a smaller market
absolutely 100% absolutely right we were
all about economics we were talking
about Derek Jeter that he's he might go
in 100 percent of the votes for the Hall
of Fame could Derek Jeter be overrated
I don't overrated I was he a for a
five-time champ I think he won five I
don't think he's overrated now has there
ever been a player that gone in with 100
now Mario levan was yeah he's a hunting
with okay
I think deer deer will be a hundred as
well not overrated they don't they don't
publicize the vote totals to go into the
Hall of Fame Basketball Hall of Fame
dinner I not that I know of
it's a secret ballot as well I think you
would you want to know would you want to
know the percentage of votes that you
got and who voted against you reg
[Laughter]
no one of my personality yes no and I
would probably hold a grudge but uh look
how very lucky and fortunate to be
selected to the Hall of Fame oh by the
way to Hall of Famers speaking to one
another right now which is kind of cool
I know right
come on right yeah you know are you no
don't I know you're turning look I can't
see you right now but I know you turned
it a little red because you're
embarrassed but to all the favors
talking right now this is kind of cool I
know but I got I got a hundred percent
of the bar you what yeah I got a I know
I did
you're a real Hall of Famer I'm just
like oh god we got to put someone in
this year let's go silly it's still one
of my favorite times that I ever had in
this business when I sat down with you
and Mark Jackson and we had cigars and
we just I was the the mediator you guys
never agreed on who's the better
quarterback the better boxer you always
had the you were opposite ends with it
and we just sat and talked and I didn't
know you I had covered mark when he was
at st. John's I knew him a little bit
but I didn't know you and I thought you
were sort of not friendly with the media
and then we sat down and just started
talking and I went man that was fun and
I still tell that story I do know we we
were the original part of the
interruption you would like the BD ater
you know you were in the middle you know
we were the early originated that you're
right it was you're right that was
beautiful it was beautiful for us
because there's always more of all
sports you are it was great to have your
opinion to be like well like what I
would say something you're like well
good point but mark is saying this is
not totally win and like we were there
for hours just talking sports which was
fabulous but at anytime I disagreed with
you or mark it would be like who Montana
or Marino and I go why I love Marino but
you know
how can you say like it was just you
guys would explode a Mike Tyson Evander
Holyfield Holyfield how can you say that
it was just we were so loud and
obnoxious that day but it was fun that
was that was first time I got to see
Reggie Aloysius Miller in full bloom
well to get back to why we're talking
about this it's because of your sports
knowledge congratulations out I don't
want to make light to be in the Hall of
Fame I mean there's a lot of people that
are all to Mike that wish wish they had
you know what you have so you know I'm
just honored to be a part of this show
and to call you a friend we've had our
differences in years past we do head
butt butt head but I love that at the
end of the day I can call you my good
friends Theodore congratulations my
friend
Thank You reg have fun Mavericks Blazers
that will be on Thursday night with
Kevin Harlan and Allie LaForce at 10:30
Eastern on TNT Thank You reg Thank You
mr. Hall of Famer thank you
Famer for more Dan Patrick show tune in
to audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]